[Music]
finally the long-awaited snyder cut of
justice league has been released
director zx snyder spoke with ign and
revealed a few more
details for instance his project is said
to conclude with an
ending sequence that is quite similar to
that of the original cut moreover
in addition to the already released 6
chapters there will be kind of
epilogue that'll stretch over 20 to 25
minutes and will be called
a father twice over despite the massive
cliffhanger as nada himself calls the
ending a sequel is not
planned however partly due to warner
brothers apparent reluctance to do so
obviously this steals the thunder from
any theories about a sequel that have
been circulating in the past
that doesn't mean though that there
isn't enough material for a sequel
snyder himself recently philosophized
and the new york times about superman
finally succumbing to the entire life
equation
and the flesh there upon traveling back
in time to rectify the events
in the interests of the justice league
members rudiments of this are said to
already be visible in the epilogue of
the snyder cat in which some heroes and
villains join forces on the dark side
controlled earth in a sequel darkseid
would then have fought the armies of the
world just as he did
thousands of years ago the grand finale
would be all the world's forces
joining together to fight the last great
battle against the villain
the film has been available worldwide
since thursday have you seen it yet
if so we look forward to a spoiler-free
discussion with you in the comments down
below
sobering news for venom fans the
blockbuster with tom hardy has once
again been given a new release date
originally sony's long waited project
was supposed to be finally released at
the end of june but as officials have
now announced
the release will be postponed again by
several months
due to the persistent unfavorable
situation to release new movies
this has sadly become quite common and
the sony is doing the same as many other
big studios have done before
for instance the man from toronto with
kevin hart and woody harrelson
is also fallen victim to the
postponements and has even been pushed
back until at least
next year the new release date for venom
let there be carnage is now
set for september 17 2021 and we can
only hope that this time the date will
actually be met as disney announced last
wednesday the production of disney's
peter pan and wendy remake has begun in
vancouver
director david lovelry and producer jim
whittaker who previously collaborated on
pete's dragon in 2016 are responsible
for the live action project
the script was written by toby hallbrook
and is said to be based in large part on
the original from 1953
which in turn is a film adaption of j
and perry's 110 year old novella peter
and wendy the cast is also quite
impressive because with alexander molly
and ever anderson
they have found two suitable actors for
peter pan and his lady friend wendy
they will be joined by jude law as
captain hook jared shahidi as tinkerbell
and jim gavigan as
me also new to the cast are alan tudyk
and molly parker s mr
and mrs darling as well as the still
unknown actors joshua pickering as john
jacoby jew as michael and alyssa
wapanatak
as tiger lily we are looking forward to
the remake of the timeless tale of
neverland
and eagerly await its release next year
after dreamworks puss in boots crossed a
whooping 552 million us dollars in 2011
the release date and the title of the
sequel has now been announced after a
period of almost
10 years the sequel is named puss and
boots the last wish
and will be released on september 23
2022
what will please fans of the first part
is that antonia banderas will once again
lend his voice to the puss in boots
the story will be about the search for
the last wish which is the only way to
restore the main character's 8
already lost lives behind the scenes
there has also been a small change of
scenery meaning that bob pasquieri will
no longer be the director
but instead joel crawford alongside him
mark swift will be responsible for the
production
not a bad combo as the two have already
proven with the golden globe-nominated
animation movie
the croods a new age we are definitely
excited about the latest master stroke
by dreamworks and are looking forward to
puss in boots too
as we reported last week james cameron's
avatar was re-released in chinese
cinemas
soon after the release it was already
evident what we and many others had
predicted
avengers end game has to give up its
first place among the most successful
movies of all time to its competitor on
release date
disney already took in around 3.5
million us dollars which is pretty
decent for film that's over 10 years old
in addition to numerous discussions
among fans about which movie is truly
the most successful one there's one
party in particular that is enjoying the
whole spectacle
namely disney so to sum it up briefly
disney has
knocked themselves off their throne and
taken it back again at the same time
while the academy awards in february of
last year were still comparatively
ordinary
this year the organizers will of course
have to come up with something different
at the ceremony on april 25th only the
nominees an accompanying person as well
as the
auditors are allowed to be on site as an
official email from david gruben the
president of the academy reveals
as every year we provide you with a
brief overview of the most
important categories and nominees minor
spoiler alert
netflix will most likely sweep the board
just like it did at the golden globes in
the best picture category the two
netflix project
mag and the trial of the chicago 7 are
among the nominees competing against
amazon prime's
sound of metal but a favorite for the
best picture category generally
considered as the most important
is a completely different film namely
khloe's house nomadland which has
already won the
all-important golden globe in best
picture drama the late black
panther star chadwick boseman was also
nominated again for his leading role in
marines black bottom after being awarded
at the golden globes and has a good
chance of being
honored anew what's particularly
noteworthy about this year's nominations
is the degree of diversity
it was already clear that chloe zhao as
a chinese director has received more
awards than anyone else before her with
a total of 56
in one award season including 13 as
ryder and 34 as a director
something else that's new though is that
due to the theatrical closures
streaming hits will naturally be the
ones that find their way into the awards
we are definitely looking forward to the
somewhat different oscars
on april 25th
[Music]
you